didn't need a charge there's a chance
when we push that button we destroy the
world we're in a race against the Nazis
Mr Nolan it is beyond an honor to get to
sit here on behalf of IMAX and speak
with you about your film Oppenheimer it
was in one word incredible and I could
talk about that all day that's been the
one word that's been on my mind for like
24 hours
but I want to ask you you know you've
been working with IMAX cameras for a
long time yeah and in a way people view
you as a Pioneer for what it is that we
do and you know can I ask you to go all
the way back to the first time you ever
used IMAX film cameras and what
impressed you so much about the
technology that you wanted to
incorporate it into your filmmaking up
until now I first encountered IMAX film
uh at museums so the Museum of Science
and Industry in Chicago had an Omnimax
Theater you know the Dome screen uh and
going to see documentaries in that in
that format
um
it really uh excited me about the idea
of applying that technology to narrative
fiction to a large-scale motion picture
um and that had never been done and then
as I got into film business and sort of
you know grew up in the industry as it
were it still had never been done it
still stayed in the institutions but the
DMR process the process of blowing up 35
millimeter films uh to IMAX that came
along in the 90s and so you started
seeing more and more imax's outside of
museums and so the possibility was there
I got to know the IMAX guys first
through Batman Begins where we blew that
film up uh and then after after that
film I I went to IMAX and said you know
could we use your cameras could we
actually start to you know shoot a major
Motion Picture on IMAX cameras we did a
little test on the prestige we shot some
of the visual effects using the IMAX
camera just to see what that that was
like
um and then the Dark Knight was the
first film where we we fully sort of
unleashed the power of you know IMAX
film cameras and we haven't looked back
we've been doing it ever since and
Unleashed you did
um I want to talk about something that
DP hoit event has talked about yeah
you know they really wanted to
experiment with putting the camera right
in your face and you really feel it in
the climax of this movie as an actor
how did that alter your approach you
know knowing that you're gonna have this
IMAX camera like right up in your face
I mean I'm a bit of a Nolan IMAX veteran
at this stage I'm kind of used to it
but this was the most uh intense use or
kind of for the actors certainly of the
of the IMAX but again you just get used
to it you know you can't think like oh
this is going to be 80 foot or whatever
you you you can't think of it like that
I mean they make a terrific noise and
you soon get used to that but it becomes
just another another tool what I what I
couldn't I remember I'm done Kirk I
couldn't get over like always who would
have the the IMAX camera on his shoulder
on the boat
um so he's a phenomenal DP I think it
also makes a lot of difference when the
camera team
uh you get very close with the camera
team I want to ask how has your
perspective of IMAX evolved in getting
to work with Mr Nolan well it's just
like the vastness and the scope of what
he creates and what you know he's
capable of and you're seeing this
director who's been so groundbreaking
his whole life
I think maybe this is his most
groundbreaking film which encapsulates
all of his talents and all of his like
endless abilities and so you need to
experience it on an expansive scale
that's what he made it for he sweat
Blitz for the audience to experience it
they say invented
all of this movie for this audience so
you've got to go see it on the biggest
screen possible that's why he made it oh
my God you guys do my job for me I don't
even say anything it's true though it's
true I agree 110 I got to see it over at
the 143 AMC Lincoln Square and oh my God
your guys's Faces by the way we're like
80 feet tall way too big
it was incredible though like it really
added to like the climax and and just
kind of like you know could you talk
about that as actors knowing that you're
gonna have that IMAX camera right up in
your face you try not to think about
that but actually you know who operate
rates and he's also the cinematographer
uh he's somehow very unobtrusive even
with that giant IMAX camera and I think
because Chris creates even at that scale
somehow such an intimate environment
where you have such creative freedom and
you're kind of hanging around talking to
each other working out how you're going
to do it and suddenly hoita has the
camera on his shoulder and and and
you're going and it doesn't feel uh so
precious it feels kind of intimate and
there's nothing different about Chris
he's like all right we're gonna do this
no don't go over there yeah do that
everything is very British and very calm
like there's no chaos you know and even
when he's happy he goes yeah good happy
all right moving on it's just everything
is very normalized and he creates a
normalized environment for everyone so
everyone's got kind of Wings of Freedom
the whole time it's really it's really
something else yeah it's it's very
nobody's pulse ever gets raised right
very cool your DP has uh has talked
about how with this film you really
explored using the IMAX camera so up
close in the intimate moments
um and you know I heard that before
seeing the film and was like okay well
you know we've seen elements of this but
then I realized no we haven't like in
the way that you did it with this film
could you talk about that because that
to me it was one of the first things
that stuck out my mind
hoita and myself we knew from experience
that when we came to oppenheim with the
IMAX format we were going to be able to
capture the wide Vistas
New Mexico the Trinity test these
large-scale things but what we talked
about a lot and what hoiser really
immersed himself in trying to figure out
is
how can this format work what can it
bring to us in terms of the intimacy
with the characters can we take this
camera and get it use it to get the
audience right into oppenheimer's head I
had written the script in the first
person I this I that you know I was
indicating
to everybody involved in the production
that we're going to be in oppenheimer's
head that's what's important and so IMAX
let's
the screen disappear you know it lets
you immerse yourself in whatever's in
front of that camera and so once an
actors got used to a very intimidating
lens very very close to the noses
um you know what we started to get and
what we started to see that we were
getting was a remarkably intimate
view into these characters lives yeah
and I think it was impactful I mean in a
way that I've never experienced and I
work it out if you could experience any
movie again theoretically any movie
again or for the first time on an iMac
screen uh what would it be and why
oh I
learned for Arabia Maybe
that's a good one that was a that was a
reference for this movie
and I re-watched it I hadn't watched it
back years and years and years and I'd
like to see that on
on IMAX you could theoretically
experience any movie for the first time
or again in IMAX what would your choices
be and why Lawrence of Arabia
I would go Lawrence maybe yes
yeah it's brilliant it's brilliant but I
would love to see that in IMAX Mr Murphy
said the exact same thing yeah that's
really funny you said Jaws I would love
to see jaws on IMAX I've never seen Jaws
on a big screen and it's my favorite
movie brilliant movie
um I'd love to see Dr Zhivago I'd love
to see one
it's always fun to see who has like a
good answer and the funny thing is
everybody usually says Nolan movie oh
yeah yeah yeah that's cool we've seen
all those on IMAX
you've gone on record as saying 15 perf
70 millimeter IMAX film is the way to
experience this movie
um you know could you talk about how how
that elevates experience and and really
just is so impactful
IMAX 70 millimeter 15 per film
is the highest quality Imaging format
that's ever been devised and so where
it's possible to present the film that
way I like to and where it's possible
for an audience to to find that
presentation uh it's an incredible way
to see it the screen really disappears I
refer to it as 3D without the glasses
you know there's this massive clear
crisp bright image that you can lose
yourself in but the other versions of
the film that we're able to derive from
the IMAX negative as a mastering former
second and an incredible right down to
ultimately hope video and you know
people watching on their phones or
whatever the quality trickles down
um we're we're starting with a really
wonderful medium for capturing
information and beauty and then we're
adapting it to all the different
presentations but where it's possible
for people to find an IMAX film
presentation that's a very special way
of seeing the film